oh my gosh that's ridiculously beautiful
thank you I can't breathe okay who needs
to breathe come on when you look like
this you don't need to breathe how how
in the world are you looking like this
you just had a baby I'm a girl told you
I can't breathe
I am zipped so tight in this dress it's
holding it's pushing things up in places
that it doesn't normally go I'm like so
it's hopefully I'll look at the picture
later that's what my Spanx do - exactly
hold it in and then pushes things around
fine this is actually your first
performance since the baby back out
there on the stage I mean not that you
know it's like it's always it's your
body is complete my body's completely
different than it was a few months ago
and it's it's always weird to kind of
come back and be like can I do I still
have it you know can I still sing
because I had an obstruction in this
area for nine months and now it's gone
so it's it's it's there's an adjustment
period and this is kind of on the early
side of me you know but it got a pretty
phenomenal voice I think you're gonna be
alright cute I hope so we're just we're
having we're having fun tonight I know I
got laid you go but I gotta ask you
about Chrissie Mets because this is her
debut as a singer live is she nervous is
she got and she's singing with you
that's a little bit of a pressure there
I mean I think we're all nervous and I
think we're nervous because we care and
this is such a special song it's part of
such a special movie that I feel like we
just all want to do it justice then we
just all want to give it our best and
make people feel inspired and just have
a moment with each other and with the
audience and with the people watching at
home so we just want to do a good job
but she's crushing it I got to see you
right before he came to the red carpet I
was like just own it own a like it's
weird it's all great we're supporting
each other right and baby boy doing good
he is he's doing good and what's the
cutest thing he's done is he do want
anything yeah and our legs just started
laughing which
the sweetest sound in the whole world
it's getting bigger and bigger like you
kind of started out making little
laughing noises it's like was it but now
it's getting more and more but he's such
a smiley baby and my other son always
was too so it's that special when
they're smiling congratulations on
everything yeah I know and phenomenal
phenomenal who is the dress by Nicolas
to run
[Applause]